a Nathan chasing horse could soon be
released from custody a judge set bail
at 300 thousand dollars for the accused
child rapist and cult leader while
prosecutors had asked for 2 million
we cannot stress enough from an
individual is charged with sexually
assaulting multiple people that they are
inherently a danger to our community
chasing horse is expected to have the
resources to post that bail he faces
charges including sex trafficking sexual
assault against a child and more an
alleged victim who was in court appeared
to be devastated with the judge's
decision coming up today at 4 5 and 6. 8
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy
will have much more on this story and we
do have more from this morning's hearing
on our website at 8newsnow.com